before we go what you can do today to
live a happier healthier more productive
life part of our partnership with
Gretchen Rubin and her ward winning
podcasts happier
research shows that 80% of a couples
fight over housework one of the most
common arguments is over who does what
New York Times bestselling Arthur that's
Gretchen Rubin is here with ways to
share the workload good morning to you
Gretchen the key word there is shoes
yeah
oh but actually taking turns often works
better because sharing can lead to
shirking it's like who's gonna unload
the dishwasher maybe you'll do it if
it's my week I'll do it on my weekend
when it's your week it's your week
that's very you really need assignments
you light it up sharing it on the fridge
yes so what do you do to get your
partner to pitch in if they're a little
okay so counterintuitive don't do it if
something is their job don't do it maybe
you want the recycling to go out right
now if it's their job let them do it and
if it backs up let it back up if you
jump in you're gonna end up doing that
chore what if we have different levels
of tolerance yes four different levels
of what's acceptable well that's really
important but these are these are
preferences and so it's not that one
person's right and one person's wrong
but let's talk about it and when you're
figuring out who gets what assignment
give people the assignment of the thing
they value if I hate having dishes and
to think that should be my job if you
hate recycling that should be your job
if they don't what if they don't do a
good job whether these are the size that
you know if you if you want to do it
right do it yourself let them do it in
their own way the more you criticize the
more you're gonna end up doing that task
[Laughter]